[Music]
J we gotta talk as Diablo you've got the
full facial tats
I mean committed facial tats after
living that way for a while in the
character would you recommend people go
that route or does it feel like a bad
idea I think I mean is it a good idea to
ask a guy with facial tattoos if it's a
good idea I would not ask a guy where's
fish now I would say great idea ya know
the tattoos were bad but I think what
was worse was shaving the eyebrows
because I'd look like the missing link
like that jump between Australia
Pittacus afrikaners and Homo erectus
that's that was me I looked like the
missing link but I was like damn they
are never gonna grow back after I shave
them everybody said you know sometimes
it doesn't grow back after I shave them
yeah I'm like you know paranoid for
seven months thinking they might not
come back
yeah because what's really crazy is you
hang out you know you become friends and
all that so you work during the week but
when you're making a movie if you shave
your eyebrows off on Saturday at the
club you don't have eyebrows yeah
everybody on the street just had pity
for me they couldn't tell how you were
feeling about anything is he surprised
is he sad I get to use your fingers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you